and we're starting right where we left
off in our last gameplay showcase just
outside Hogwarts which I I love that we
can you can walk out of the castle after
walking through everything and then just
come out here and take off on your broom
out into the open world and Alan I know
that's something that you particularly
like about Hogwarts Legacy too yeah I'm
I'm uh I'm a big fan of just being able
to hop on the broom and go anywhere
there's something about kind of like the
the sensation of of everything being
open to you and just I love the
proximity that I can get to things I
love flying close to the ground and and
I I kind of wanted to talk about it just
because I feel like
um you know the brooms are fun for me
not just because of all those feelings
of exhilaration but but because they're
not just I have a broom and it's done I
actually kind of like some of the
mechanics in it so you can you see in
the lower right there's a meter there
and and occasionally as Andrew's kind of
flying up or flying down you might
notice it in draining or not and and
this isn't the present day where all the
broom technology is well known and
advanced and and everything that we know
and love this is an earlier time where
they're still trying to figure out you
know we're not at the 3000 yet we're
like we're at the 11. so I just I'm just
so speechless right now because this is
just so beautiful the world this looks
so by the way the the broom is like the
only one or can you like operate the
brooms yeah so we have uh stop in Hog's
meat actually a broom shop and so that
sells a variety of different brooms and
it was important to us that the player
could customize themselves based on
their own Aesthetics so they're purely
cosmetic but uh if you talk to the
shopkeep and help him out he'll actually
sell upgrades
and those those upgrades will make it so
that where normally the broom you can
only fly
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo meter down there
you can only go at Max Speed without the
meter going down kind of closer to the
ground and as you raise into the air
you'll notice the meter drop and so
those upgrades will allow you to
increase that distance from the ground
and there the the broom owner at at the
sporting goods store in in hogsmead is
trying to perfect the broom and get
better at it and and know it better and
you can participate that and get better
and better brooms through this I see and
I love that that mechanic encourages you
to actually explore the world and kind
of stay close to the ground it's not
just a travel mechanic point A to point
B you're not just flying high over
everything although it is beautiful
something I really love doing but as
well there's lots to lots to explore on
the ground and so kind of keeping you
down at the ground level to me it feels
like it's got this kind of Surfing Vibe
over there like I'm just like I want to
snatch the controller from Andrew right
now because I want to go to the
Mountaintop I'm going to the forest
enter that Hamlet
we're gonna we're actually gonna land
here and I I feel like I feel like that
you call it a hamlet is is just perfect
just because that's what we refer to
that is and so uh we all know for more
that hogsmeade is the only all Wizarding
village within Britain but we wanted
other opportunities to kind of meet
other characters out here and to kind of
populate the landscape so it's not just
kind of you know Barren as you leave out
this direction in that direction and so
we just imagine these different
dwellings these different smaller
locations that that Wizards might live
in out in the Scottish Highlands and so
it's those uh and so we refer to those
as hamlets and their opportunities to
learn those wizard stories
um how those different locations have
kind of like learned to live what their
relationships are with characters that
Hogs me from Hogwarts and so they're
both Quest opportunities out here and a
chance to kind of get to know more of
the area even Beyond Hogwarts and
hogsmead that we've already experienced
and you'll also notice on the mini map
like lots of little icons and each one
of those represent gameplay in in the
hamlets that you can participate in you
know whether it's a vendor or different
puzzles and challenges or different
secrets that exist each one of those
icons are different opportunities for
gameplay and you'll notice that that
same thing as we venture out into the
open world as well so when you go out
into the open world and you see see
those icons whether they're on the mini
map or on your map or off in the
distance those things are opportunities
to say like I want to increase my
inventory capacity their puzzles left
behind by old Wizards you know that you
can solve that actually Grant you those
if you see ruins off in the off in the
distance and you visit them you might
find Opportunities to actually expand
and learn about your ancient magic and
as you and as you kind of encounter
different enemies dotted on the
landscape sometimes those characters
poachers or dark Wizards might be
hoarding different uh magical resources
that are valuable to you as you're
playing the game so each one has kind of
like a way to connect to our gameplay
loops and provide different
opportunities that just kind of reward
you for poking around them and mean I
right away when I want to just cover all
of those points on the map
but we've flown on a broom already but
there is something that we haven't done
so far and that is uh getting on our
flying Mount we're gonna hop on our Onyx
hippogriff here the Onyx hippogriff is
our pre-order bonus oh my God then he
just like tops out of the
the back oh wait you can you
use it of course yeah um as a hippogriff
you can you can totally write it like a
ground Mount and you can lift off into
the air and we tried to make sure that
each each of those interactions so the
broom's really good at reaching that top
speed at that kind of traveling the
world as quickly as possible but
sometimes it's really nice to get on the
hippogriff because of that ground speed
or those Transitions and sometimes it
just feels amazing just to be riding
around on it
yeah it's it really is kind of like uh I
don't know it's a great feeling being on
it and it's a great feeling managing
those transitions kind of going from run
to fly and just being able to go
wherever you want and we tried to make
sure that that though that each one of
these things that you can interact with
have have a unique identity and a reason
for being
and oh my God like I see like different
like areas like a swampy area by the way
can you go to like entire map anywhere
you go there are regions that are like
locked from you yeah as soon as as soon
as you there's kind of a moment where
the world kind of opens up to you
outside of Hogwarts as a student and
right from that moment early on in the
game you can go wherever you want and so
you might find more difficult challenges
in different areas and you'll see
different spots as Andrew's moving
around like you mentioned the swamp but
there we have got like a coast and we've
got different types of environments out
in the world just to kind of uh pepper
your experience reward you for exploring
keep things fresh all those things exist
I love that windmill it's like so rustic
like I keep forgetting that this is like
1800s The Wizard World we've never
really sing before like it feels so
authentic like it just it's part of it
yeah I love this Vista too and and I'm
gonna have Andrew stop here we're gonna
use a bit of Dev magic to uh change the
seasons actually I want to see I want
you to see what this world looks like uh
with covered in snow yes yes please I
love snow
oh baby
[Music]
oh this is so beautiful oh my goodness
this is so pretty okay it was so
realistic
oh my God it changes the landscape like
completely oh my God does it have like
actual like gameplay impact like an
impact on the gameplay or does it like
it's just the weather of Scotland uh
yeah we use it we really use it as a
narrative marker through through the
game so as you're progressing through
your main storyline it was important for
us to kind of like have those moments
that kind of felt like when you're
reading the books or watching the movies
where you know you'll see kind of like
the title card winter and now the
landscape has changed and you're really
feeling those that passage of time while
you're a student you know going through
your year at Hogwarts and I think I
think we wanted to duplicate that and
for me it's really fun that it's not
just on the outside which which I I
agree I think it was really beautiful
um but within the school as well so
there are moments like when it reaches
certain holidays or things like that
where hogsmead
holidays and the school reacts to
holidays and you see the decorations
around those environments change that
really helped just kind of make me feel
like I'm there right and and it's not
just uh it's not just you know for the
seasons those those kind of vibe things
um like we have a day night cycle and
that day night cycle it even though
similarly like it's largely about Vibe
when you go into hogsmeade in the
evening there's less characters there
around the school you'll notice it kind
of dies down and quiets down just I mean
there's just Candlelight and students
kind of like as you're walking through
the Halls
but in that day night cycle is where
we've kind of placed a few items where
you know whether or not you can collect
them or whether or not you can interact
with them with that are a little bit
restricted by the day night cycle
and I love Andrews flying up here really
high up on the hippogriff and and we're
just looking at this view of Hogwarts in
the distance it's just absolutely
beautiful it's part of what I love most
about flying around in this game whether
it's on a hippogriff or or on the Broom
now I I mean you talk about going
anywhere and things that you can see in
the distance and that's one of my I I
still can't get over like no matter I
play this so much but I still I still
can't get over the fact that I can see
Hogwarts out there and there's just
something beautiful about knowing about
all of all of the things inside of it
the classrooms the students the
professors all the places I can go I can
just fly my hippogriff land in the
courtyard enter the front doors and just
walk you know to the library to class or
two Greenhouse or to my common room that
it's all contiguous and just kind of
like one one space is still exciting to
me after all this I mean I'm just just
I'm speechless right now it's just
absolutely beautiful it's just as much
as we want to spend a lot more time out
here just flying around experiencing the
world I think this is a great
opportunity to switch over to combat and